will he or won't he
president trump has given his strongest
signal yet that he will be running for
president in 2024.
for legal reasons uh president trump
cannot yet announce that he's running
but during an interview with sean
hannity the former president did not
exactly play
coy where are you in the process of
or have let me ask you this without
giving the answer what the answer is
have you made up your mind yes
[Music]
i think you got it right yeah have you
made up your mind
yes not well i'm considering well i'm
looking that's what that's what
politicians do
when they want to keep the idea going
that they'll run but they don't really
want to run
trump says yes i've made up my mind
can't give an answer yes you're going to
be really happy with my answer yes yes
yes
some republicans think that it would be
the absolute worst thing in the world if
trump runs again i for one
i'm not so sure about that i think
republicans have a lot to learn
from the donald and from other past
leaders actually from other past
donald's
including the legendary defense
secretary don rumsfeld who died
yesterday
it's getting harder to learn these days
because we're losing all of our
standards in our schools
on capitol hill in our own private lives
but on this show
today and every day we will insist on
standards i'm michael knowles this
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from lilia rosales who
says
michael is reading the nsa statement and
paying attention to every word like a
spouse that was cheated on
truly that's where we all are now yes
that's true
parsing every little you know you find
your uh your cat of a husband's cell
phone and you're parsing every word this
that and the other thing
because the trust has been broken
in a marriage that's gone awry the trust
has been broken
in our relationship to the federal
government these agencies that are
spying on us and they're
deceiving us about spying on us that the
trust is broken so we've got to parse
every word
and by the way when you parse every word
on that ridiculous nsa
non-denial denial about spying on tucker
carlson
when you parse every word you realize
wait a second they didn't they did not
deny
what tucker carlson is alleging the nsa
look just looking in on all of your
electronic communications so you're
probably going to want to keep those
communications safe
if you want to i would strongly
recommend start mail
free email services like big tech email
providers
are not really free they're not now you
don't maybe give your credit card but
you know what you do pay with
your privacy since those companies have
access to every email
you send and receive big tech can sell
your data to the highest bidder i think
we've heard about this recently with a
very famous conservative commentator
on a very very famous cable channel some
people may be peeping at his emails
if you want to protect your data and
your emails i would strongly recommend
you check out
start mail start mail will keep your
email private
every email is encrypted even if the
recipient does not use encryption
which means big tech can't read scan
analyze or sell
personal information ever with start
mail deleted means deleted when you
delete an email
poof it's gone forever and start mail
uses their own servers
not big texts which means they can't be
put out of
business start mail is also backed by
the most stringent privacy laws in the
world you get unlimited anonymous
aliases
so when you're giving your email to a
company but want to protect your
identity
start mail can generate a shareable
alias email so people can't sell your
information and they can be deleted
any time if this week hasn't taught you
to to seriously protect your data i
don't know what will
head on over to start mail.com knowles
s-t-a-r-t-mail.com
knowles for 50 off your first year
startmail.com
knowles i know that trump has flaws
i know that he created some problems for
himself that he probably didn't need to
i know that he made some wrong turns on
policy i'm thinking of the first
the jailbreak bill the first step act
and some other problems
but compared to the republican
establishment
i think that guy's got the right
impulses and i think a lot of the
republican establishment politicians
really do not
an example of this i hate hate to
criticize our own side but i suppose i
have to
representative kevin mccarthy was he's
the
house gop leader he was speaking about
a bill that would take down confederate
statues
in the capitol and you know this is a
problem throughout the united states do
we tear down
the confederate statues and kevin
mccarthy is supporting this bill this is
a bill that is being pushed by democrats
but mccarthy is supporting it and the
reason behind why he's supporting it i
just
it's just a little weak
but let me state a simple fact all the
statues being removed by this bill
are statues of democrats madam speaker
as i heard the speaker talk earlier
about
removing of the four portraits of
speakers in the hall
the same answer goes for that as well
they were all
democrats what's interesting the statues
that need to be removed
were sent to the capitol by states that
were majority controlled by democrats
sent
to a house that had a majority
controlled by democrats
accepting of these statues so
the the question is do we tear down our
history do we tear down our monuments do
we tear down
the art pieces that were
put up to support a reconciliation
between the north and the south after
this bloody horrific civil war
do we tear those things down and
the left is the one pushing for tearing
down the statues because the left hates
our history
and they don't just hate robert e lee
and they don't just hate
whoever stonewall jackson they hate
lincoln
and they hate washington and they hate
jefferson and they want to tear down
those statues too and they've been
tearing down those statues for
at least a year and a half now but
kevin mccarthy here is taking this
tactic of saying oh yeah please tear
down the confederate statues
why they're democrats yes the democrats
are the real racists
yeah that's right that'll show you
democrats
i'm going to give in to that policy that
you guys are pushing
i'm going to give in to that policy that
you are making a big national political
issue and you don't even realize how
owned you just got
no i don't think they got owned i don't
think they care i don't i don't think
the democrats today
feel any care about the fact that
andrew jackson or any of the
confederates or any of the bad people in
history were democrats
okay i don't i think they just want to
tear down our nation's history and i
think it's so
so short-sighted to say well yeah robert
e lee he was a terrible rotten traitor
we should tear down anything that in any
way represents the south the whole point
of putting up the statues in the first
place
was that we need to bring our country
together with malice toward none and
charity for all
so much well you know we're not going to
hear that line from abraham lincoln much
longer because we're going to tear down
his statues too
it's just so it is just such weak sauce
the democrats are the real racist i mean
the left takes this way too far and they
say the party's switched which just
didn't happen it's not as though one day
all the republicans and democrats sat
down together and said okay
the year is 1964. from now on you guys
are going to be the democrats and we're
going to be that's not what happened
that's preposterous but parties do shift
over time and
parties change and not even that they
come to resemble one another but they
just change in and of themselves
tearing down our history especially
history that was put up to reconcile the
country
is just a bad idea and it's part of the
broader ruthless withering criticism of
the country
and it's it's part of the the attempt to
reframe our history and make america
look like the bad guys which is the
entire point
of the 1619 project now i don't want to
be too hard
on kevin mccarthy i think a lot of
boomer republicans
are pulling these same lines i think
it's just ridiculous i don't think they
should do it i think they need to
realize
that uh these little cheap rhetorical
flourishes are not going to work very
well
but mccarthy mccarthy's doing some other
other good stuff too mccarthy
demanded yesterday that an investigation
be launched into explosive allegations
that joe biden's administration spied on
tucker right so
so tucker goes out makes this claim says
the nsa is spying on me i got the
receipts
the nsa fake denies it they non-deny
deny it
and that we're going to leave it at that
right but no at least kevin mccarthy is
looking into that
this is a much more important issue than
whatever the next tax cut is
i love tax cuts as much as the next guy
but this is a much
much more important issue than
whatever the usual republican fare is i
just wish
that republican leaders would recognize
that these cultural issues are it's
they're all kind of connected right the
idea that the blob is going to spy on
americans and
eat away at our political tradition the
idea that we're going to tear down
statues not by the way not just of
confederates but of
all of our other forebears as well the
idea that we're going to reframe
american history
it's all part of the same revolutionary
project the the establishment
by which i me i mean the blob i mean the
administrative state and
big tech and the media they're all kind
of in the universities and the schools
they're all working in concert they are
not going to give up power they're
taking power from the american people
from the constitutional system
and they are changing it this has been a
process that's going on for a hundred
years it's going on since at least
woodrow wilson
they are not giving up power l.a county
right now
la county officials are calling to lock
down again
they're calling for the masks again
because of the indian variant
which we're not even allowed to call it
the indian variant by the way
the who told us we have to we have to
use the greek alphabet now
so it's not the indian variant it's the
delta variant it was fine when it was
the uk variant
because white white guys are terrible so
you get forget about you know they're
they're awful people
spanish flu they find by me too but the
minute that you're talking about
a non-western country you're talking
about india or something that's very
racist you're talking about the china
virus where they actually invented the
virus
no that you can't say it's the kovit 19
it's soros cove ii
it's the delta variant and
and because there is this new variant
we've all got to lock down again do you
do you see where this ends it doesn't
that's where it ends from the very
beginning of this epidemic
i have basically been licking doorknobs
okay i've been greeting people on the
street with a french kiss
almost okay don't i'm joking by the way
we're gonna get to bill cosby later i
don't want anybody to accuse me of
anything
but i have been very
inclined to ignore all of the advice
from the dr fouches of the world because
those people are liars and they've
squandered all their credibility
and now they're just doing it again it's
18 months
we're 18 months into this thing we're
supposed to be 15 days and you know what
it's going to go on for another 18
months if
you let them do not let them just tune
them out when you want to tune out all
the crazy noise out there by the way i
would strongly recommend
raycon when you want to tune out all the
crazy noise outside when you want to
tune out you know
people who are just making a lot of
cacophony when you want to listen to
your favorite
audiobooks podcasts i don't know maybe
maybe both of those will be by little me
who knows music
you've got to check out raycon wireless
earbuds
you put those raycon earbuds in your
ears they will make all the difference
no matter what you're listening to
crisp powerful beats at half the price
of other premium audio brands
i have tried the competitors and i've
paid
for the competitors and i'm just telling
you raycon's a superior product okay
it's just the way it goes
raycons are built to go wherever you go
they look great they've got a great
comfortable in-ear fit they've got great
cool colors
great compact charging case right now
raycon's offering 15
off all their products for my listeners
here's what you've got to do
to get it go to buy raycon.com knowles
there you will get 15
off your entire raycon order and it's
such a good deal
you'll want to grab a pair and a spare
that's fifteen percent off at
byraycon.com
slash knowles by raycon.com knowles
a very legendary politician has just
died
that man would be donald rumsfeld
don rumsfeld twice defense secretary
defense secretary for bush one i think
he was the youngest secretary ever at
that point
then defense secretary for bush two i
think he was the second oldest secretary
at that point
uh he was a congressman he uh was chief
staff to
jerry ford he had a pretty legendary
career
it's all all over the place and he had
he had these kind of
pithy lines he had rumsfeld's rules that
would circulate around washington
he went out on a sour note because he
was presiding over the iraq war and
everyone just blamed him for why the
iraq war
didn't go very well and he bears some
blame but he really doesn't bear all the
blame that people heaped on him
don rumsfeld had one of the most famous
lines in politics
over the past 20 30 years and people
made fun of him for this line but i
think we need to learn
i think it actually contains a lot of
wisdom i will let him put it in his own
words reports that say there's
that that something hasn't happened
are always interesting to me because as
we know
there are known knowns there are things
we know we know
we also know there are known unknowns
that is to say we know there are some
things we do not know
but there are also unknown unknowns the
ones we don't know
we don't know people made fun of him for
this
for for weeks and weeks no knowns no
none what are you talking about don
rumsfeld
this is one of the most sophisticated
observations that has
come out of our political system in a
very long time
saying there's some things that we know
that we know there are other things that
we know that we don't know it's a gap in
our knowledge but we're at least aware
of the gap
and then there are other things that we
don't know that we don't know and those
are very very dangerous
now the the philosopher slavoy zizek
actually took this a step further
and he said no knowns known unknowns
unknown unknowns and then there's a
fourth category
the unknown knowns
stick with me here i know it's a little
confusing
the unknown knowns are the ones that i
think we've
really got to focus on today because
that is what has subtly
changed our entire culture slavoy zizek
says there are some things
that we don't know that we know
we know things but we're not aware that
we know them
that is ideology ideology
is very often the thing that we we just
don't even know it we're just it's like
fish swimming in water it's the air that
we breathe
and so we're just not aware of it but it
shapes so much of what we do
this is the topic of my book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
which is
available now national bestseller so
thank you for everyone who has uh
who has ordered the book i'm glad it's
getting very nice reviews on amazon so
thank you for people who are
leaving those there the way that the
left
twists language in particular but
institutions as well
is so subtle that it just smuggles in
premises it smuggles in whole views of
the world
and we are not even aware that that has
taken place
but we just use these kinds of lines
okay they're they're doing it right now
in a very clumsy way with the the
pronouns that's why there's a fight
ordinarily they just smuggle in this
language and it's no big deal
they did it with same-sex marriage very
easily they
and subtly they said you know marriage
for all of human history had been about
the
sexual difference at the most basic
level it involved sexual difference
then they just smuggled in this idea
they said you know it's like a jedi mind
trick
marriage does not involve sexual
difference there is same-sex marriage
and then
because we just used that word and we
said of course yeah marriage doesn't
involve sexual difference these are not
the droids i'm looking for
sure so yeah so then the question is who
deserves the right to get married well
everybody deserves the right to get
married okay that's it
right and it's just it just subtly
does that the the way that we went from
a bum
to a [ __ ] to a homeless person
to now an unhoused person to the housing
insecure
people and so you're just subtly
shifting blame away
the bum is responsible for his condition
the unhoused person why he's just a
victim of circumstance
ideology defines which one those are
going to be do we have
do we have an ideology of personal
responsibility do we have an ideology
of oppression at the hands of in the
case of our society the straight white
men who know that they're men in the
patriarchy and all of that
we need to be very aware of that we're
seeing this with this olympic gal you
know the olympian who
she got third place in the olympic
trials for throwing a hammer and then
she
used the opportunity to disrespect the
american flag and in so doing our entire
country and all of her countrymen
remember that and then she wants to go
represent the country at the olympics
so this this lady i'm not even going to
say her name i don't i don't think we
need to reward
this this individual's temper tantrum
and and anti-american activism
by saying her name and giving her
publicity which is exactly what she
wants but she went on some
television show that i haven't haven't
heard of and she explained herself
she said she wasn't not disrespecting
america she just
she just hates the star-spangled banner
know your history you know the full song
of the national anthem
the third paragraph speaks to slaves in
america
our blood being slain and and piltered
all over the floor
it's disrespectful and it does not speak
for black americans
it's obvious there's no there's no
question
uh the third stanza of the of the
star spangled banner does not refer to
slaves blood being slain slang and
piltered
all over the ground because those aren't
words i mean
i suppose they're slang is a word but it
doesn't it doesn't mean what she thinks
it means until i've never heard of
piltered i don't so it's not english
that's why
that's not that's why that's not what's
happening in the third stanza
second of all the meaning of that verse
which is uh
refers to the hireling and slave
and about how how no refuge will save
the hireling and slave
the meaning of that verse is really not
clear in
in some play it may refer to american
slaves but it also very
likely refers to the german troops for
instance that the british were hiring
and who who were purchased from german
princes it uh may refer to the british
process of impressment uh
the author of the star spangled banner
never made clear what he meant by that
expression
uh regardless though let's just say it's
even right let's say it's referring to
slaves who went and fought for the
british and and the star spangled banner
talks about how terrible they are
nobody sings the third verse who's
whoever sings the third verse of the
star-spangled banner
nobody it's a completely contrived
problem because
you're using the excuse of a line about
a slave that
may or may not refer to american slaves
as a justification for getting rid of
the whole
star-spangled banner as part of the
project of reframing american history
there's there was a national anthem well
now there's a black national anthem
which is sometimes played at public
events
there's an independence day well now
there's the juneteenth
national independence day the new
national independence day there is the
traditional understanding of america
centered around the goodness of the
country and the founding fathers now
there's the new
reframing of america put forward by the
1619 project
it's just a new shift this woman says if
you know your history you know this she
doesn't know her history she doesn't
barely knows the english language but
what she does know is ideology and she
doesn't even know that she knows it
this is the unknown known
this sick ideology that is totally
contrary to our country and contrary to
her flourishing and the flourishing of
all of our countrymen
has just seeped in and she's not she's
just swimming in it she's not
not even aware of it she goes on though
she says yeah i hate the national anthem
i totally disrespected it
but i still want to play in the olympics
i never said
that i didn't want to go to the olympic
games
that's why i competed and got third and
made the team i never said
that i hated the country never said that
all i said was i respect my people
enough
to not stand or acknowledge something
that disrespects them
i love my people point blank period i
mean i learned that family matters
um despite the economic oppression that
we faced growing up
you know i still have my family and my
grandmother she did
everything she could to make sure that
we survived and had a roof over our head
and that's special very interesting
language she's using here so first it's
so silly she goes i'm not disrespecting
the country uh well if you disrespect
the star-spangled banner
which is the symbol of the country you
are disrespecting the country if you
disrespect the symbol you're
disrespecting the symbolized
that's why symbols symbolize things well
i still want to play in the olympics
yeah i know you do but
it's not about you lady it's about the
team which represents the country
then she uses this subtle line she says
yeah we faced economic oppression
growing up oppression not
we had economic troubles not we had
economic suffering which
a lot of us have probably all of us have
at some point in our lives or the vast
majority of us do
oppression it was somebody else's fault
it wasn't because a family member ran
away it wasn't because a family member
didn't didn't go work hard it wasn't
because someone made bad choices it
wasn't because someone
wasn't able to overcome it wasn't it was
oppression somebody did this
to us through no fault of our own
is that really how life works is life
really that simple i don't think so
then she says that's not i'm not saying
i hate the country i just love my people
what do you mean your people do you use
a popular rejoinder what do you mean
you're people
who are your people here she's he's
she's obviously implying black people
and she's saying that the national
anthem is against black people this
star spangled banner symbol of the whole
country is opposed to black people
and so when push comes to shove she's
going to side with the black people over
america because she sees them
as being at odds i don't see them as
being at odds
i actually the only way we can have a
country is if we believe that our people
are the american people
there are gradations of identity there's
a national identity
state identity local identity religious
identity
racial identity family identity the
basic political union she says i love my
family
right in order to have a flourishing
society all of those things need to be
in order of accord in
in subsidiarity to use a technical term
okay
they can't be opposed to one another but
increasingly what we're seeing
is division between well actually even
within the family especially
the left is trying to sow that and then
between the family
and the state and the state and
the country and the races obviously
they're trying to gin up racial
division and sexual division they're
trying to put that all against one
another
in order for the country to flourish
your people has to include all of those
things
down the family up to the race and the
community and everything all the way up
to the nation ideology has warped that
it's taught her a lot of things she
knows that she doesn't even know that
she knows
ben today is going to be talking about
some of the sexual perversion going on
including kink for the kitties we'll get
into that a little bit too i'll be
talking about bill cosby
go check that out you know also history
tends to be painted
as dry and boring but not on daily
wire's new podcast america's forgotten
heroes
these seven action-packed episodes
illuminate men whose heroic
acts have not received the recognition
they deserve the first episode concerns
union soldier joshua lawrence
chamberlain who dashed directly into
history at the battle of gettysburg
by strategically charging the
confederates and narrowly dodging a
bullet that grazed his cheek
on the way his actions were pivotal to
the union winning such a hard-fought
battle
and many americans don't even know his
name subscribe now to america's
forgotten heroes on apple podcast
spotify or
anywhere you might listen so that you
can catch the first episode which is
available today thursday
july 1st if you like what you hear leave
a five star review and help share these
incredible stories thank you for
listening
thank you to the heroes that have made
such a terrific podcast
possible by the way go order speechless
controlling words controlling minds the
libs are really upset that the book is a
national bestseller
so i appreciate all of you who have read
it and i hope that more of you continue
to read it and write in to me and let me
know what you think unless you don't
like it then don't let me know we'll be
right back with a lot more
racial grievance is probably
the the most significant form of
currency today
it can get you out of anything that lady
at the olympics who disrespected the
american flag in the whole country at
the olympic trial she says well you know
but it's my people and the oppression
and the grievance and okay
she's probably going to get off the hook
this is true even
at fairly high levels of politics lori
lightfoot
mayor of chicago the one thing i kind of
respect about lori lightfoot
is her just absolute brazen cynicism
she doesn't try she doesn't really try
to glad hand she just
she's just a pure power
corrupt machine politician and there's
something you got to give a grudging
respect to that
so lori lightfoot is in big trouble
because crime is spiking throughout
chicago that place is like fallujah
right now
crime is way way up she's she's lying
and pretending that it's down year over
year but you've seen huge spikes
you know up in crime in shootings and in
murders
and lori lightfoot says the only reason
people are complaining about this
is because she's a black woman
there have been questions raised about
your your temperament and
your reaction to criticism tribune
editorial use the term
erasable how much of this do you think
might have to do with the fact that
you're a woman
and partic specifically a black woman
about 99 of it look at my predecessors
um did did people say that rich daley um
held uh you know uh t sessions
uh with people that he didn't disagree
on uh ron emmanuel
was a polite um guy who was a uniter
no women and people of color are always
held to a different standard
i understand that i've known that my
whole life
that's it she's such a victim the mayor
of chicago she's such a victim
you know so she can't succeed
she can't become the mayor of a major
american city no because of the racism
amazing amazing how that the racism
didn't prevent her from rising to a very
high political position
but it is causing her to be criticized
has nothing to do with the bullets
and the deaths and the the
riots that took place and the looting
and the arson
and the murders no no it's just because
she's a black woman right
by the way if you dare if you dare
criticize
that kind of line of argument oh man the
establishment is going to come after you
especially
if you are a white person especially if
you're
a white dude oh that's really bad there
was a host
on msnbc tiffany cross who
just recently attacked bill maher bill
maher is a
liberal but he's a white guy and he's a
liberal
who is not totally politically correct
and so he
sometimes goes after the excesses of the
woke people and you know he
reserves most of his criticism for the
right but a little bit for the left
that was too much for msnbc
delves right into the identity politics
of identity politics
this is a black woman saying that that
white man
needs to shut his mouth okay bill maher
has been whack for a long time from his
make out session with the blackface
expert megan kelly
to his infamous use of the n-word on his
show for which he later apologized
and his continual mostly white weekly
panels where he sings
sob songs to them about the perils of
the shrinking demographic
and shines anyone who falls even
slightly outside of his myopic
privileged view anybody find it
interesting that this quote-unquote
liberal ally
is sounding a lot like a moderate fox
news contributor
bill maher you do not get to tell people
of color what they should or should not
be offended by stay in your lane slim
try that instead of standing on your
alabaster perch every week to crap on
other people's lived experience
while providing a safe haven for
well-established white supremacists
because i gotta tell you this old angry
white man act is
so played the truth is what's happening
now is an
evolution and you are fighting for your
power and privilege to not become
fossilized while basking in the rays of
your own non-existent cleverness and
comedy bit
circa three decades ago and quite
frankly it's just offensive at this
point
the country like it or not is changing
in real time
and sadly fake time with bill maher is
not
whoa man this woman is a vile
vile racist right do you i mean i know
the word racist doesn't mean anything
anymore
because the left has watered it down to
mean nothing but if racist means
anything it means that woman
right this entire attack is on bill
maher because he's white
his alabaster perch stay in your lane
white man
how dare you question the lived
experiences of black people how dare you
question the lived experience of that
white guy named bill maher
by your own logic you're saying one
cannot
ever criticize the opinions and actions
of someone of another race right but
that's exactly what you're doing and
you're doing it
on the basis of race even crazier
you'll very often hear the left
say that there is this crazy conspiracy
theory
that the left wants to
replace white people as a demographic in
the united states and that they're
cheering it on as the process of
immigration and
things like that lead to a declining
demographic that's a sick
white supremacist conspiracy theory
she's
she's the one articulating it she's the
one saying the demographics are changing
it's inevitable you're losing your power
and that's good this is evolution you're
you're ossifying
you're turning into a fossil on the
basis of your race
and other races are gaining in power and
we're gonna have a racial politics
and you just need to shut up and take it
that i don't know of any well first of
all how many white supremacists are
there in america i don't know like three
and they all work for the fbi but
but i've never heard of a white
supremacist
articulating that alleged conspiracy
theory nearly as clearly as that woman
on msnbc
vile vile politics
that's what she's saying to him this is
it i
i don't think that she knows what she's
saying
i don't i think she much like
the the broad the left broadly
and this leftist broad by the way i i
think that she is
living in the unknown known that this
just this ideology is blinding her
to the the glaring contradictions in
what she's saying or
if it's not a contradiction or if it's
not hypocrisy then it's just this double
standard and it's double standard along
the lines of race
and to a lesser degree sex in this case
because bill maher's big transgression
is not just that he's white but he's a
white
man and that's very terrible and you're
not not allowed to criticize anybody
that is ideology the ideology is not
just in the racial realm
and by the way this this woman's vile
racist attack
not not even the creepiest craziest most
radical thing we've seen in the past few
days washington post
piece by lauren roello
yes kink belongs at pride
and i want my kids to see it
kink what is kink you know there's
sexual
orientation there was the homosexual
rights movement men who were attracted
to men
then some women who were attracted to
women then there was the transgender
rights movement men who think that
they're women women who think that
they're men
and then there's this idea of kink which
is what uh drew drew will sometimes use
the uh
the british expression the old slap and
tickle
that's you know that's kink it's just
when you have some kind of unusual
sexual fetish or sexual fantasy and that
is now considered not just some kind of
quirk because
mankind has fallen and we've all got
kind of weird things going on in our
head
that is now considered a full-on sexual
identity
and not just a sexual identity but
because sex is now so central sexual
desire so central to everyone's
sense of self that is a very basic
identity
so this woman just i won't go through
this entire disgusting
disgusting article but uh she's talking
about
how she takes her little kids to
go see this pride march and
she says that her wife is trans but
wasn't
out at the time so i guess that means
her wife
is does that mean her i don't know what
that means i don't know
it's heart is it a man to a woman or a
woman to a man whatever
so she typically only expressed her
authenticity in the privacy of our home
but she wore green skirt and light
makeup brushing her hair to one side
that was her okay so i guess it's a man
who thinks he's a woman or something
anyway they bring the kids to this pride
parade
and then as we got settled our
elementary schooler pointed in the
direction of oncoming floats
raising an eyebrow at a bare chested man
in dark sunglasses
whose black suspenders clipped into a
leather thong
the man paused to be spanked playfully
by a partner with a flog
what are they doing my curious kid asked
as our toddler cheered them on
the pair was the first of a few dozen
kinksters who danced down the street
laughing together as they twirled their
whips and batons
some leading companions by leashes
at the time my children were too young
to understand the nuance of the
situation i told them the truth
these folks were members of our
community celebrating who they are
and what they like to do and then
she goes on to explain how happy she is
that uh
her kids are watching perverts spank one
another in thongs and and leather
other suspenders obviously
these children should be taken away from
this
mother this mother is sexually abusing
her children
we told you this would happen you in
this case i genuinely do hate to say i
told you so often i jokingly say i hate
to say i told you so
in this case i actually am sorry to say
that i told you so
when whenever the sexual revolution has
progressed from the 1960s to the present
conservatives have always said this is
going to lead to this and this is going
to lead to this and this is going to
lead to this and this is going to lead
to the sexual abuse of children
and every step of the way the left and
the sexual revolutionaries have said
oh give me a break that's just the
slippery slope argument oh come on give
me a break
in every single instance the slippery
slope has been correct and now i think
we're
basically down at the bottom of the
slippery slope i do actually explain
in my book speechless available now to
order how it was kind of always baked in
if second weight feminism is true and
men and women
are basically the same they're
interchangeable a woman needs a man like
a fish needs a bicycle
if that is true the only difference is
between men and women are superficial
then obviously you've got to redefine
marriage
because men and women are the same so if
if marriage is the union of one man and
one woman but men and women are the same
then obviously marriage must include the
union of two men and two women
but if that's true then obviously you
have to have
transgenderism because if men and women
are exactly the same and the only
differences are superficial
why then men can be women and women can
be men maybe they have to get a little
cosmetic surgery but that's it
then then it's all the same
and by the way if this is true if that's
a fact of human nature
that men can be women and women can be
men and there's really no difference
why then of course you've got to do it
to children you've got to permit
children to
to transition that's not even a question
of consent
that's just uh that's just a fact of
nature
right there are plenty of things
children don't consent to because
children can't consent to anything
because they're they haven't reached the
age of reason or the age of maturity
so you know chil parents decide what
their children are going to eat
parents decide where their children are
going to go to school and parents now
will decide whether their children will
express
themselves as a boy or a girl because
that's just a fact of nature that was
always going to happen
the problem is it's just wrong and the
right wing arguments from
consent or free choice or individual
liberty and
total misunderstanding of liberty or
individual autonomy or whatever
they ain't going to cut it you've
actually got to be able to draw a line
and say
exposing children to perverts spanking
one another in thongs
is wrong it's abuse there needs to be a
consequence we need to enforce
a consequence we need laws against this
and we need punishments for the people
who transgress those laws
speaking of sexual perverts
they are not just taking place at the
kink section in the kitty area of the
pride parades
they also exist in our jails and now
some of them exist
outside on the way out of our jails
namely bill cosby
bill cosby hey hey hey getting off the
hook
bill cosby was exposed for
lots and lots of creepy sexual acts over
his career
and the story was always a bit
convoluted
because these stories came out only
decades and decades later
women at the time did not seem to think
that they were
exactly rape or they maybe they were but
they kept
maintained relationships with cosby for
professional reasons or even personal
reasons
and then later on they say no i really
was abused and then so finally one of
these cases that was
not outside of the statute of
limitations that finally got god cosby
thrown in the clink well
cosby now is getting getting out on a
a bit of a technicality but the
technicality was this cosby was brought
to a civil trial so there's a difference
right civil is
money criminal is jail time cosby's
brought up
on these civil charges and the
prosecutor says if you
admit to doing certain things we will
not prosecute you for them so for the
purposes of the civil trial
just admit it just say you'll do it and
then we'll carry on with the civil
issue and you'll be you'll get immunity
on the on the criminal
charges so he does that and then they
they basically pull the rug out from
under him and say
actually nope sorry uh we're gonna
prosecute you so he goes to jail
and now cosby is getting out the
the issue with the cosby story is
everyone is really trying to
oversimplify it
so on the one hand you've got the metoo
movement which is saying this guy
is a just the worst rapist in the
history of america
and it's just clear cut and he's like a
guy in an alleyway
that's not quite true bill cosby was not
a guy in a dark alleyway
bill cosby was a very very powerful guy
in hollywood
who used young women for sex and
some women used him for professional
advantage and
that doesn't excuse bill cosby's
behavior in any way but it complicates
the story a little bit it's kind of like
the weinstein story
the weinstein story was complicated
because many of his
victims people who claimed that he raped
them
continued seeing him continued a sexual
relationship with him for a long time
because he was one of the most powerful
people in hollywood
and they felt either intimidated that
they would be
in danger if they spoke out or they felt
that they would lose their career and
many people did lose their careers when
they did speak out against him
which furthered the issue it's a much
more complicated sexual issue
now some people have taken the complete
opposite position said look
in a lot of it maybe not every case with
cosby and with with
harvey weinstein in many cases though
that and actually
i suppose cosby is harder because he
would actually drug these women but in
some cases the women took drugs
voluntarily and
repeated times but it's a little easier
with weinstein because weinstein was
so transactional so much of the time but
they'll take the complete opposite
they'll say this isn't rape this isn't
it doesn't mean
in at least some of the cases it doesn't
meet the criminal definition of rape and
so
these guys are off the hook there is a
third option here though
the third option is standards the third
option is
even if cosby and weinstein in most of
these cases were not
predators lurking in a dark alleyway
late at night even if there was
complexity and nuance and even if there
were relationships here and even if the
relationships went on afterward
and even if the women at the time in
some cases didn't think it was rape but
later did
even then what they did was
intrinsically
wrong it is intrinsically wrong
to pressure women into effectively
becoming prostitutes
to advance in their career it is
intrinsically wrong
to indulge in what was obviously bill
cosby's weird sexual fetish
kink i guess you'd call it of sleeping
with drugged up women
that's that is in itself wrong but we're
not allowed to say that anymore the
reason that no one
very few people only only even just a
handful of conservatives not even a lot
of conservatives go squish on this but
the reason that it's so hard to take
that position
is because you have to say that there is
a purpose
for sex that sexual acts the rightness
or wrongness of sexual acts
does not merely rely on consent consent
is obviously an important factor
but it does not merely rely on it that
some sexual acts even if the parties
are both willing participants some of
them are still wrong
i'm reminded of the marilyn manson story
marilyn manson the
he's that very popular singer who is
also probably the most famous satanist
in america
gosh who would have imagined that the
world's most famous satanist
is not not necessarily the greatest guy
in the world he
had a long-term relationship with evan
rachel wood and evan rachel wood now
comes out later and says he pressured me
he abused me whatever
meryl manson says it was consensual they
both might be right
they both might be right but but the
degrading sexual acts that they engaged
in were intrinsically wrong it was wrong
of the guy to do it
speaking of weird sex stuff a biological
male
who identifies as female cataluna
enriquez is now
miss nevada usa was grounded that way on
sunday
the first male contestant to become miss
nevada
okay nobody did this because
this guy is the most beautiful of all
the women right and they all did it
because of ideology i remember when i
was at yale
there was a it was like a mystery yale
competition and when i was there they
gave it to
a woman and this was this was a great
win right but no one did it because they
really thought
that the woman was the coolest guy on
campus or whatever
they did it because of ideology they did
it to prove a point it was
it was just that thing that we're all
kind of floating in well of course why
can't
why can't a man be miss nevada because
he's a man
well but but no but it's just it's all
about just our free choice and our
self-expression and our identity
no i don't think so tarantino made this
point
quentin tarantino movie star speaking of
some weird sexual desires
tarantino was on bill marshall of all
things and he said that art has become
so ideological now there has become a
thing
that's gone on it seems like in this
especially this last year
where um uh um
what's the word i'm looking uh uh
ideology
is more important than art way more
certainly to the awards
yeah and it's just you know it it's like
you know ideology trumps
art ideology trump's individual effort
ideology trump's good
ideology trump's entertaining right he's
hitting on something we're all much more
aware of this but the reason we're more
aware of that is because the radicals
have upended what was the general
consensus there used to be a
standards and a tradition in america
that we all kind of agreed on and we
were not aware of it because
and it gave us the ability to have a
broad private realm
the the personal was not so political
because it was all just settled and we
all agreed
and then the radicals came in upended
all of that unsettled all of that
and then everything became up for
ideological debate that is a process i
talk about at length in speechless
exactly how that happened because of
that
we must fight the political battle
we can't we will not be able to go back
to de-politicized de-ideologized art
before we win that political battle it
was settled
it's been upended and it's up for for
contest right now and we will
either win or lose that before it
settles down again
and then it will float back into the
background as it unfortunately is
beginning to do
on the left's terms and we will all just
exist again in that
in that unknown known i'm michael
knowles is the michael knowles show
see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 today on the
ben shapiro show bill cosby goes free a
columnist pushes lgbt king for children
in the pages of the washington post
and president biden is caught between a
moderate rock and a radical hard place
that's today on the bench bureau show
give it a listen